Bonjour à tous !
Et bienvenue dans...
Je suis Léo.
Et je suis Pierre.
Le concept de...
Est plutôt simple.
En fait, pour faire court...
Donc... c'est relou là !
Franchement...
Qui c'est qu'on va accueillir aujourd'hui ?
Et bah je te le donne en mille, mais je crois qu'on va accueillir...
Horia, la youtubeuse, oui effectivement.
Horia la youtubeuse !
Bonjour, bonjour les gars.
Comment vas-tu ?
Ça va !
Bonjour, bonjour les gars.
Comment vas-tu ?
Ça va !
Aujourd'hui le défi sera simple...
C'est de piéger la clientèle
D'un magasin de cosmétiques.
Tu as déjà travailler dans une boutique...
Ouais !
De cosmétiques ?  - Exactement !
J'ai déjà été vendeuse... voilà !
Ok !
Tu seras à l'aise avec ça ?
Pas du tout !
Oooooook !  - C'est parti !
Oh non ! T'es relou !
Fais moi un signe de JUL s'il te plait.
Merci beaucoup.
La première cliente que tu vas aborder
Tu vas faire "bonjoureu".
Bonjoureu
Je peux vous aider ?
Conseille lui de juste mettre de l'eau sur son visage la matin.
Si vous voulez avoir bonne mine il faut mettre de l'eau le matin hein.
Juste de l'eau.
Froide.
C'est ce que j'ai fait un peu parce que moi je suis en putain de gueule de bois là.
Moi c'est ce que j'ai fait parce que là je suis en pleine gueule de bois.
Vous avez des enfants ?
Oui.
Oui ?
Combien ?
Deux.
Ah !
Moi j'ai horreur de ça.
Ah j'ai horreur de ça.
Rigole comme une chtarbé s'il te plait.
Dis "je suis très seule".
Oh je suis très seule.
Propose des massages de mains au gens.
Es-ce que ça vous tente un massage des mains gratuit ?
Du coup tu l'assois et tu lui dis que c'est une caméra cachée.
Non en fait c'était une caméra cachée.
Regardez, là ! Là ! Là !
Bravo !
Vous me reconnaissez pas ?
Non.
J'ai été figurante sur Les Trois Frères.
J'ai été figurante dans le film Les Trois Frères.
Demande lui si tu peux lui faire la bise.
Je peux vous faire la bise ?
Fais en 10.
Ah d'accord.
Vous aimez les bisous !
Demande à sa fille de partir, elle vous gêne.
Excusez-moi vous pouvez partir par contre.
C'est ma nouvelle maman.
Je suis avec ma nouvelle maman donc...
Et vous partez pas ?
Y a leur sac, y a son sac...
Cache le.
Demande lui si elle fait le tri de ses poubelles.
Et vous faites le tri de vos poubelles, de vos déchets ?
Mais asseyez à côté de moi.
Vous pouvez vous assoir hein, si vous voulez discuter.
Vous vous ennuyez.
Je reviens.   - Allez y.
Maman ?
Demande lui si elle aime les manèges, et si elle dit oui...
Tu lui tournes son siège.
Vous aimez les manèges ?
Encore.
Vous voulez pas me faire tourner ?
Je dois te raconter un truc. Excusez-moi madame.
Reviens en étant triste et dis que tu t'es fait virer.
Je suis choquée...
Vous pouvez pas pleurer ?
Elle me regarde même pas.
Propose lui un massage des joues...
Et en fait tu colles tes mains sur ses joues...
Et tu les bouges pas pendant 5 minutes.
Je vais vous faire un massage des joues.
Je me suis pas rasé en plus...
Me parlez pas monsieur.
Moi je prends pas assez soin de mes mains.
Bah il faut hein, les hydrater surtout là avec l'hiver qui arrive.
J'ai envie de vomir.
Ah j'ai envie de vomir par contre là.
J'ai trop bu hier soir encore.
Non, non sans déconner j'ai envie de vomir.
Non j'ai vraiment envie de vomir moi.
Et bah je crois que je vais...
Je vais le faire, je vais vomir.
Je vais vomir je pense.
Ça y est.
Et vous savez quand j'ai envie de vomir, bah je fais des squats.
Continue et chante en même temps...
"Je fais de toi mon essentiel..."
Je fais de toi mon essentiel.
Ça a l'air d'aller.
Le massage vous fait du bien ?
Ça vous fait du bien le massage alors ?
Oui ?
Parce que c'est encore 2 minutes hein.
Y a encore 2 minutes.
Dis lui qu'en réalité tu bosses pas dans le magasin.
En réalité je bosse pas du tout ici moi.
Je vends des brioches.
Pour rigoler bah je fais ça.
Non mais c'est vrai !
C'est fini ?   - Oui c'est fini.
Bah en tout cas ça m'a fait vraiment plaisir.
Bah ça glisse beaucoup hein.
Et du coup vous allez partir sans m'avoir rien acheté ?
Du coup vous prenez rien du tout ?
Vous achetez pas ?
C'est dommage parce qu'on a une boutique, on vend des choses, j'aimerais bien que...
Faut l'acheter hein.
Moi ça me fera des chiffres.
Comme ça, ils seront contents.
Je peux vous refaire la bise du coup ?
Si vous voulez.
T'en fais 20.
J'ai arrêté de compter.
Allez on s'en refait 10.
Bah du coup on va s'en refaire 10 hein.
Allez !